翻訳: Toshiro Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさんにとって 音楽とは
どのようなものでしょうか？
携帯やiPodに入れて 電車や車の中で
楽しむものかもしれませんし
ある人にとっては
カラオケで発散したり
仲間と一緒に音楽会を開いて
楽しむものかもしれません
今日 私がみなさんにお伝えしたいのは
「音楽は既にあるものではなく
共に作っていくものだ」ということです
これは 私が障がいのある人や
プロのミュージシャンたちと
一緒に活動を続ける中で
確信したことです
実は 私は 「美しい音楽とは何だろう？」
ということが
小さな頃からずっと疑問でした
幼稚園の頃から クラシック音楽の
ピアノを習ってきたのですが
コンクールで賞を取ることがあっても
舞台上で賞をもらいながら
なぜ自分が賞をもらえているのか
分からない —
そういう不思議な感覚でした
家でピアノの練習をしているときも
指を動かしながら
なぜ自分が練習できているのかも
分からない —
そんな感覚でした
こういった疑問はどんどん大きくなって
私は大学に入って
専門的に研究を行うようになりました
「美しい音楽」というのが
既にあるのであれば
それをきちんと知りたい
と思ったのです
例えば 障がいのある人と一緒に
音を介してやりとりすることができたら
それこそ 本物の音楽かもしれない
と考えました
そう思って
障がいのある人と出会ってみると
一緒に過ごす時間は とても楽しくて
私は 「この人たちとなら
私の探し求めている音楽について
一緒に探し求めていけるのではないか？」
と思いました
けれども 実際に障がいのある人と
音楽作りを始めてみると
思ったようには簡単にいきませんでした
「これなら美しいメロディーだろう」
と思って 歌いかけても
全くなんの反応もなかったり
それからリズミカルな伴奏を
ピアノでしてみても
全然 ノリを一緒に
感じられないこともありました
私はとても焦りました
でもそれは 実は私の中の音楽という枠組みが
とても狭かったからなのだということに
だんだん 気づき始めました
一緒に音楽をしているシーンを
振り返ってみると
実は 障がいのある人たちは
とても独特な方法で音楽をしていました
例えば 私が 「ドソドソ」と
ラッパで吹いた時があったのですが
その時 その子は
まだ６歳の子だったのですが
高い声で 「まいにち まいにち」と
声を重ねてきました
なぜ 「毎日毎日」なのか
私にはとても不思議だったのですが
「その子なりの独特の価値観が
既にあるのだ」
ということを感じることができました
こうした経験は私にとって
「音楽とは何か？」という
大きな発想の転換になりました
実は こうやって 私が
音楽に対する考え方を変えることができたのも
「Free Improvisation」 あるいは
「フリーミュージック」と言いますが
少し変わった 自由なスタイルの
即興音楽との出会いがありました
どんな音なのか
少し聴いてみたいと思います
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
私が初めてこのようなライブを
聴きに行った時
とても衝撃でした
その時ライブで出演していたミュージシャンは
ギタリストだったのですが
ギターを横に向けて
ちゃぶ台のような脚をつけて
そこにホースをつけて
らっぱをつけたりして
サイバーギターと呼んでいたのですが
しかも そのギターから出る音は
普通のギターの音ではなくて
電気コードがいっぱい繋がれていて
ものすごいノイズを発していました
聞いたことのない音楽でした
また その時 一緒に演奏していたのは
サックス奏者だったのですが
舞台に正座して座り 延々と
途切れのないメロディーを吹き続けていました
なぜ窒息しないのか？
私には不思議だったのですが
あとで「循環呼吸」という
特殊な奏法だということを知りました
どのように共演が成り立っているのか？
どうやって音を出しているのか？
私にはとっても不思議だったのですが
でも だんだん
そういうライブに何度も行くうちに
だんだんとその音楽の世界に
惹き込まれていきました
こうして障がいのある人と音楽をやりながら
またもう一方で
即興音楽のフィールドに身を置き
自分でもライブに参加してみたりしながら
私は 「この２つのフィールドが
もし出会うことができたら
そこに新たな表現を作りだすことが
できるのではないか？」と考えました
「障がいのある人はコミュニケーションを
取るのが苦手だ」と言う人もいますが
実際は独特な方法で
コミュニケーションを取っていて
即興ミュージシャンと一緒にやったら
とても素敵に音楽が聞こえてくる
のではないか？という風に考えました
また 即興ミュージシャンたちも
もし 障がいのある人と
一緒に音楽をすることができたら
また違った生き生きとした音楽を
作り出すことができるのではないか？
という風に考えました
そう考えて 「音遊びの会」
という会を作ったのは
2005年9月 —
今から10年前のことでした
私はその時 まだ博士論文を執筆中の
学生だったのですが
同じ大学院の仲間と一緒に
「新しい音楽表現を開拓しよう」という
目標を掲げて 始めました
１年で終わるはずが 10年も続き
その間に山口、東京、北海道
それから イギリスまでツアーに行ったり
活動の様子がドキュメンタリーになって
公開されたりもしました
少し どんな音楽が生まれたのか
ビッグバンド「音遊びの会」での定番
といわれる演奏をお聞かせしたいと思います
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
（拍手）
（声）ありがとうございました
これは 音遊びの会が始まって
７年目の京都公演の出来事でした
こうしたビッグバンドが生まれたのも
実は始めはそう簡単にはいかなかったのです
色んな試行錯誤がありました
はじめ ゲストで呼ばれた
プロのミュージシャンたちは
「言葉で通じ合えることができない人と
本当に音楽ができるんだろうか？」と
とても不安に思ったようです
でも色々なアイデアを考えてくれて
障がいのある人たちも含めて
一緒にビッグバンドができないかと
考えてくれました
それで ものすごく簡単な指揮 —
例えば ポンと指を振り下ろしたときに
「大きな音を出すよ」ということを
やってみたのですが
振り下ろしても 全く大きな音が出ずに
少し後で 小さな音が
「プス」と鳴るだけだったり
また 「じゃあ今度は小っちゃな音だよ」
と言って みんなを引きつけて
「よく聞いて」と言って
やってみたのですが
今度はバッハの『メヌエット』が
流れ始めたりして
思ったようには全然いかなかったようです
とても落胆して「壁に向かって
指揮しているみたいだった」と言って
「二度とやらない」と言って
やってくれませんでした
でも 「障がいのある人たちを
なんとかしてまとめなきゃ」と思ったのが
そもそもの間違いだったようです
永井君は障がいのある子ですが
彼に任せてみると
すごくリズミカルな方法で
格好良いサウンドを
皆をまとめて作り出すことができました
こうして 色々なアイデアを試行錯誤しながら
ミュージシャンたちも
「音楽とは何か？」という考えについて
色々と更新させていくことができたようです
「音遊びの会」の保護者もまた
だんだんと変わり始めました
ある舞台では 掃除機を持って
アンサンブルをしたのですが
少し その映像をご紹介したいと思います
（音楽開始）
（音楽終了）
保護者のみなさんは
最初このような音楽に出会ったとき
「これって音楽なの？」と
とてもびっくりしたようです
「もっと子どもがいつも慣れ親しんでいる
ポップスや童謡などをやって欲しい」
「学校で習っているように
楽譜のある音楽もして欲しい」
「子どもが戸惑っているんじゃないか？」
という意見までありました
でも実際にこうやって
舞台に立って一緒に演奏に加わったり
それから 子どもの音楽について プロの
ミュージシャンに褒めてもらうことによって
とても自信になっていったようです
始めは 「こんな掃除機を演奏するなんて
お掃除おばさんみたいで 嫌だわ」と
神戸のマダムたちは 言っていたのですが
当日は 演奏手順を紙に書いて
プリントアウトして 配る人もいて
とても ノリノリに演奏してくれました
音楽に対する考え方が
保護者のみなさんもまた
変わっていったようです
音遊びの会では
舞台に出て演奏に加われなかったり
客席でずっと歩いていたり
それから 舞台に出ても
演奏中にだんだん寝てしまう人もいます
でも そういう人たちも
「存在」という肩書きのパフォーマーとして
トランペットやキーボードを
弾く人のように 認められています
こんな風に音遊びの会では
色々なアイデアを今でも試しながら
ワークショップを続けているのですが
だんだんとやっているうちに
皆がその価値観を認め合うことが
できるようになっていきました
こうして 理解しながら
音遊びの会 独特の音楽が
出来上がっているように思います
こうした 活動を通じて 私は
「音楽とは既にあるもの」ではなく
「共に作っていくものだ」ということを
思うようになりました
あるミュージシャンは「人は皆
自分自身の音を持っている」と言います
私は最近 「音遊び工房」という
新たな活動を始めたのですが
そこでは プロのミュージシャンが
特に関わらなくても
観客が驚く舞台が
次々に生まれています
その時 その場所に集まった人同士で
たとえ 技術や価値観が
とても異なったとしても
「音楽とは何か？」という
前提を外して 一から始めてみると
そこに新たな音楽シーンを
作り出すことができます
障がいがあってもなくても
民族や文化が違ったとしても
音楽は関係性の中に作っていくものだ
と考えることができたら
私は 「皆が共に音楽文化を
創造していくことができる」
と考えています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）